MOLLY STEVENS: So
welcome, everyone.
Thanks everyone
for coming today.
I'm actually going to let the
designers introduce themselves,
because I think they'll put
it much better than I would.
So why don't we go
ahead down the line
and make introductions?
JENNA BILOTTA: I'm Jenna.
I am currently the co-founder
of Avocado software.
We make apps for
couples, so public
and private communication
and collaboration.
Formerly of Google
long time ago,
worked with some
of these folks that
are on the stage and many
of you in the audience.
And currently I'm just focused
on making venture capitalists
hug their iPhones during demos.
RYAN FREITAS: Hi, my
name is Ryan Freitas.
I am the co-founder of about.me,
and I run product there.
Trained as an interaction
designer, formally
of adaptive path.
The about.me story is one
that some of you may know.
It's an identity platform
that was acquired
very quickly after
launch by AOL.
We spent two years
inside, we bought it back,
and I now run the
product independently
alongside my
co-founder Tony Conrad.
CHAD THORNTON: Hi,
I'm Chad Thornton,
I'm a design manager at Uber.
Back in the day I
was also at Google,
and then after that co-founded
a couple startups, and then
joined Airbnb as a
first UX designer.
BRADEN KOWITZ: My
name's Braden Kowitz,
I'm a design partner
at Google Ventures.
I worked at Google
for about four years,
and then for the
last five years I've
been helping all the startups
that Google Ventures invests
in, helping them be
better at design.
So we just go from product to
product and startup to startup
and help them with everything
from user research,
to product design, to
branding, just everything.
MOLLY STEVENS: Great.
So there've been a lot
of great presentations,
we've seen a lot of design
over the last day and a half.
And there may be
designers here who
have come up with
startup ideas, or have
things they'd like to build.
So what's maybe
one thing that they
can learn from your
startup experience?
Anyone want to take this?
BRADEN KOWITZ: I
think it's hard.
Every startup
experience is so unique
that the advice you'll
get on a panel like this
is going to be very general.
We'll try to do our best,
but individual questions
are better.
So save some for the
end, and find mentors.
For me, the biggest
thing that I've
learned working with startups
is how fast you have to iterate.
But you can work on something
and believe it's amazing,
and then end up
showing it to people
and find out very quickly that's
not the thing that they want.
So the faster you can
get into testing out
your ideas the better.
RYAN FREITAS: Absolutely.
And I think one
of the things you
can do beyond understand the
speed at which things move is
to educate yourself around the
business of what you're doing.
Design founders are
often at a disadvantage,
not have ever been exposed
potentially to some of the ins
and outs of financing,
the legal perspective.
Make certain that you
walk into the situation
completely prepared, or
as prepared as you can be.
It is extraordinarily
advantageous
compared to somebody
who doesn't know
exactly what they're
getting into.
MOLLY STEVENS: I think that's
an interesting point that really
would love to hear more about.
Talk to me a little bit
about the transition
from being a designer
at a large company
or an independent
designer in school
to being part of the business,
making the business decisions
and doing things like that.
So maybe Jenny you can
talk about that a bit.
JENNA BILOTTA: Yeah, so I left
Google and YouTube after almost
six years and created a
startup with just myself
and my co-founder, and right
now we're at six total people.
And I think the biggest
thing is that you don't just
get to do design.
You're responsible for your
company's bank account,
and your employees' salaries,
and your health insurance,
and making sure that
their families can thrive,
and that they are acting
like normal human beings.
And then on top of
all of that, you
have to do all of the brand
thinking, all of the design,
all the interaction
specs, all the icons.
5,000 million launcher
icons for Android,
making sure that looks all good.
And you basically
have to shed your idea
that you can be responsible
for perfect, super high-quality
design, because you have so
much other stuff going on.
And then there's the
lawyers and the trademark,
and the competitors and
wondering what they're up to,
and you don't just get to do
design as a designer founder.
BRADEN KOWITZ: Yeah,
I feel very much
the same way in
that designers like
to say it's not
just how it looks,
it's how it works as well.
And when you get into
the startup world,
it's how it looks,
it's how it works,
but it's also what it
is, and the value you're
trying to create for people.
And then even deeper than
that, how you put together
a team that figures out how
to deliver that value over
and over again.
And so a startup designer, yeah,
you can do that top-level stuff
and you're very good
at it, but you're
going to need to work at
those lower levels as well.
CHAD THORNTON: I
think when you're
in this world where you don't
actually know if the business
model's going to work
out, you have to just
be a lot more diligent about
always ask that question
and testing that out.
And be comfortable not
shipping the best product
if you can learn from
it faster, if you're
more willing to iterate,
if you're setting up things
in a way that you're able
to learn faster, really.
JENNA BILOTTA: I think one
other thing is that when
you have so few resources.
Like going from a
company like Google,
where if you happen
to fall asleep at 4:00
in the morning like
normal human beings
do and some emergency
happens, there's
always somebody else to
address the emergency.
When you're a founder and
the buck stops at you,
and so you're responsible
for everything.
And there is no other resource,
there's no release valve.
If somebody on your
team doesn't do it,
you have to do it,
whatever that thing is,
and a lot of times
that's not design.
RYAN FREITAS: Absolutely.
The design piece that you may
get comfortable with early
on in your career, once
you become a founder,
is one of your many jobs.
And we talked a
little bit about this,
about the pressure
of, OK, I'm supposed
to be the lead designer.
I'm supposed to touch
everything first.
I'm responsible for this
going all the way through.
How do I balance that
with everything else
I'm supposed to be doing?
And you hit upon it early
in your first answer
with, you are responsible
for these people
and your entire team's ability
to provide for their families.
And the weight of that
responsibility is tremendous.
And sometimes your choices are
between make the business work
and make certain this
is pixel perfect.
Pixel perfect loses
almost every time.
JENNA BILOTTA: And you also have
to focus, at a really small pre
product market fit
company, you have
to focus on growth
over anything else.
So if you have a
bug, it doesn't get
fixed, because it's not going
to help with user growth,
or acquisition or
anything like that.
And so your priorities
really change.
And as a designer who
at a larger company
was focused on
quality, and precision,
and making things really
tight within the design role
that you were given, you have
to give almost all of that
up and just be like, what
can I do to get this done?
How fast can I to grow?
My bank account is
draining out, like--
RYAN FREITAS: It's a
series of terrible choices.
BRADEN KOWITZ: I think
that's hard for people,
too, because you want
to be a good designer
and what is good
design is things
like this beautiful
animation behind us,
and this beautiful
space that we've got.
This is great design.
And so as a small startup, you
want to look big in some ways,
and you want to spend a lot of
time doing that polish work,
but oftentimes that's not the
right stuff to be focused on.
It's a tactic.
You could say, we have
to deliver delight
because we're doing a game, or
we're doing a financial product
so it has to be polished
enough so that people
believe that it's trustworthy.
But that design is just
a tactic that you can use
and you can employ,
or you can focus
on other more important things.
JENNA BILOTTA: You said delight,
you have to take a shot.
MOLLY STEVENS: So there's
a lot of pressures,
a lot of things going on.
So let's talk about how you
make some decisions about how
to focus on-- make
good design decisions,
instead of only focusing
on what's urgent.
I think that's a decision that
we all make as user experience
folks in anything we do, right?
People come to us,
something's very urgent,
but you have to decide how
you're going to move forward.
So how does that
happen at a startup?
RYAN FREITAS: I think
pushing the decision making,
the hardest thing as a
founder is the belief
that all the decisions
need to come from you,
and that's something you need to
abandon as quickly as possible.
You have to democratize
that as quickly as possible,
and get everyone to
understand that the team is
responsible for the
delivery of quality
and excellent experience.
And that may mean different
things to different people,
but we've been at it
for a number of years.
The consistency of our
delivery reinforces
that every person who's
brought into the team
knows that we have standards.
We have a belief in
providing specific tools,
a particular experience.
If those decisions continually
have to go through one person,
there's going to be a point
at which it'll all collapse.
MOLLY STEVENS: So
another thing that
comes up when we think
about startup design
is investor-directed design.
So someone comes in
and says, oh, you
should make it a different
color, or something.
Talk to me a little
bit about investors,
and key figures that might
be involved in startup design
you didn't expect.
JENNA BILOTTA: I think this
is where you and I disagree.
RYAN FREITAS: Totally.
JENNA BILOTTA:
This is my tactic.
Sure, sure, yes.
Yes, of course, that's
incredibly brilliant,
thank you for your
time and attention.
RYAN FREITAS: I think
that's where I started out.
The first company
that I was with,
I was an early design
employee, and there
were investors that were very
interested in making comments
about the design, the
direction, and I was like this.
I had no absolutely
no use for it.
Over time, I think I've matured
my perspective a little bit,
if only to think that these
people are actively invested
in you, and your team, and
the success of the product.
Some of them see far across
their own portfolios.
They get pitches from people who
aren't even in the portfolios.
They're seeing tons
of tremendous ideas
that you-- you're focused.
You're building
your own company,
you're not seeing the
things that they are.
So it's a balancing act, right?
I think I went
from, no, F off, I
don't want to listen
to any of this,
because it's going to pollute
my perspective on my--
JENNA BILOTTA: The bottom
lines are totally different.
I'm responsible for building a
market and building a product,
and they're responsible for
making their investment grow,
right?
They're focused on money, and
I'm focused on product quality.
And those two things are
oftentimes mutually exclusive.
And the time that they devote
to thinking about your product
deeply is so surface that
you can't really get great--
I mean, unless you have an
amazing investor like Braden--
BRADEN KOWITZ: So the
way I think about it,
so you're absolutely
right that when
someone who's giving
you a million dollars
says make the button
blue, you're like,
should I make the button blue?
RYAN FREITAS: But
good investors don't
make those kinds of directives.
They show you
other things that--
BRADEN KOWITZ: I think of it
much like customer feedback.
So you talk to customer,
and they're like,
I want a faster
horse, you don't just
go try to make a faster horse.
You go like, why
do you want that?
And you dig a
couple levels deep,
and then often you get
to things like, well, I'm
worried about
distribution, how you're
going to get this to customer.
Or I'm worried about whether
you can really scale and make
this thing in a certain way.
And when you get to those
core issues or fears
they have about
your business, then
you can start to figure out
what to change in your product.
CHAD THORNTON: The
thing I've seen work
well is, it's hard to do it.
If you can get a number
of investors in a room
and make it almost more like
sort of an earlier-stage
brainstorming we session, it
puts them more on their A game.
Because they're
investors with investors,
RYAN FREITAS: Absolutely.
You've changed the
context entirely.
I think there's a natural
instinct for designers
to-- they have an
allergy to dilettantism.
Somebody who doesn't have
the background that they do,
coming in and making commentary.
And the easiest way to
transform those conversations
into something
helpful is to ask, OK,
this is your art
direction feedback,
in the service of what goal?
Let's get back to
core principles.
Why do you think this
change is necessary?
And then we can actually
explore solutions in the way
that a good design team does.
JENNA BILOTTA: I think any
individual investor might
have some reasonably thought
out design advice for you,
and I don't know how you got
all your investors in the room
at the same time, because
that seems impossible.
But collectively, if you
have more than three or four,
they are like the worst
client you've ever had.
They all have
different feedback,
it's mutually exclusive, it's
to serve their own purpose,
and you can't reconcile
it within the design
in a reasonably holistic way.
And so you don't
know what to do.
Like, you have five or
six people telling you
that wrote you
really big checks,
that they feel really strongly
that the option be free or not
free or whatever, and
you have to listen,
but then your other
investor will be like,
oh no, it has to be free,
and one will be like,
oh, it has to be
paid, like you have
to have a business
model right away.
And what do you do with that?
RYAN FREITAS: The
most important piece
in any of that, though,
is a designer needs
to maintain their point of view.
They have to come
back to, this is
what I wanted to put
out into the world.
If they're opening that up
to speculation or suggestion
from everybody and anybody,
then they've lost the plot.
They don't know what
road they're on.
JENNA BILOTTA: A lot
of times like investors
aren't designers or
even product people,
and they're finance people,
they're like business people.
And so they will give you
the most randomizing design
feedback.
Like, oh, if you could
make it like Snapchat.
Your things go disappear,
like if you could just
be Snapchat, that'd
be really cool.
Like, if your app
was just-- like maybe
you just change the
name from Avocado
to Snapchat, and like
maybe release that.
They don't know how
to give feedback.
They're not trying to not, so.
MOLLY STEVENS: So that
might not be great advice.
JENNA BILOTTA: Full
of horrible advice.
MOLLY STEVENS: So lots of
people will come to you,
they'll give advice, you'll
ask users for advice.
There's all kinds
of ways people want
to have input on your thing.
What's the best
startup design advice
that you've gotten from
an unexpected source?
JENNA BILOTTA:
Remember to be human.
It's easy to forget when you're
trying to ship a product,
trying to find out if it works.
And the line between
yourself and your company
is so blurry that when an
investor comes up to you
and says, oh, well, the
company's not really
working out the way
that it should be.
It's like really
underperforming or whatever.
You feel like that's
talking basically
directly into your soul,
and it's really easy
to forget you're a
human being and you
have to separate from
the design and you
have to let some
of the design go,
and you just use have
to let some things go.
You literally can't
do everything,
and you have to remember
to be a human being.
I don't know where
that advice came from,
but it was good advice.
CHAD THORNTON: I
think the advice
you gave earlier, what was it?
Get a therapist, and a--
RYAN FREITAS: And
a personal trainer.
CHAD THORNTON: And
I mean, yeah, that
sounds silly, but like--
RYAN FREITAS: It's
trite, but it's true.
JENNA BILOTTA: I'll
+1 the therapy thing.
RYAN FREITAS: If you're not
taking care of yourself,
god, you wind up in a
situation where you're
under tremendous pressure
that you are sharing day
to day with only one
person, because you
want to keep that
away from your team.
We've been talking quite a bit
about the [BLEEP] umbrella.
You're trying to
stay above them,
making certain that they don't
get covered by everything
that's raining down
on them constantly.
That takes a toll, both a
mental and a physical toll.
You have to make certain
that some part of your day
or some part of your week
is devoted to making certain
that you're all right.
JENNA BILOTTA: It's
also really lonely.
When you're working
on a big company,
you're working on
a team, but you're
working with other designers
and user experience
researchers and stuff.
And these are people that
understand you and speak
your language.
But when you're in a really
small team, if you're
less than 10, you're not
going to have two designers.
Like, you're it.
And well, I hope-- maybe
you will, I don't know.
I would hire 10 engineers
before I hired a designer.
But it's really lonely,
and you don't have anybody
to bounce ideas
off of that is kind
of in the design profession.
Basically, I picked a buddy of
mine that I used to work with
and sent him mockups on
the sly and was like, hey,
can you just tell me if
this is crazy or not?
Because you start to
really feel crazy.
Like, am I building
the right thing?
Is this boring?
What am I doing?
RYAN FREITAS: Yeah, the lack
of peer input is daunting,
it's really difficult.
BRADEN KOWITZ: To that
point, almost all the startup
designers I talked to who
were at small companies
feel very lonely.
Like there's no in their company
that can give them feedback,
there's no one to give
them a reality check.
So for them, we try to be that
support on our design team,
but also it's great
if they can create
a mentorship, a set of people
that they can get coaching
from.
JENNA BILOTTA: Where were
you when I needed you?
I was so lonely.
MOLLY STEVENS: That
sounds like one idea might
be having kind of a Las
Vegas for designers where
they can go and share stories
and it all stays there, right?
It doesn't go anywhere, so.
BRADEN KOWITZ: The other big
thing that I've learned is that
often when teams are fighting,
and they're-- we should do
something, we should
do A, we should do B,
and they fight back and forth.
For me, I've learned to see that
as the canary in the coal mine
that we don't have enough data.
Often you don't realize
what you don't know,
it's this invisible
thing, this unknown.
But when you start fighting
really hard about what
you should do, it's
usually good indicator
that you probably
don't know something.
So that's a great time to take
a step back and think about,
what is it that we
don't know, and could we
design an experiment, or a
test, or do customer interviews,
or do something to
bring data into that?
So that instead of spending
all of our time arguing,
we can very quickly get
into execution again.
RYAN FREITAS: Do you think
entrenched opinion is a sign
that the good questions
aren't getting asked?
BRADEN KOWITZ: Yeah, absolutely.
Or that you don't
have enough data
to sway the other people along.
RYAN FREITAS: In more
mature organizations,
what is that like?
What have you seen?
I mean, you've seen at
mid and large scale.
CHAD THORNTON:
Yeah, I mean, I feel
like the larger the organization
gets, the more diligent
they get about using data
in a variety of useful ways.
Early on, it's hard to stay
disciplined and actually
say, like, what is the
hypothesis we're testing,
and how can we
actually validate this?
You hear all of the
internet with lean startup
this and that.
But to actually
see that through?
Unbelievably hard.
RYAN FREITAS: There
are organizations
that do KPIs and goal setting
really well, and then, I mean,
you've see across the portfolio.
I don't know how many small
stage startups are really
good about saying-- you
talked about making decisions
based on growth.
Other startups have
different goals,
but if every decision is not
coming back to something,
some kind of goal, then
you can very quickly
wind up losing exactly
what you're trying to do.
JENNA BILOTTA: Well,
and then there's
all the accidental successes
where something just went crazy
and they didn't really take
the time to understand why,
and they're like,
yes, more of that.
Just keep doing the
thing that we were doing,
and then you realize a
year in or two years in,
you're trying to build a
business and the founder,
God bless them, but--
and I said them, not him,
but they just stumbled
into this luck
and they don't actually
know how to run a business.
That's when you need
to bring in an adult
to handle the situation.
But I don't know.
It's a whole lot of luck, and a
much smaller amount of talent.
RYAN FREITAS: No one
knows what they're doing.
JENNA BILOTTA: No one
I mean, that's the
secret of tiny startups,
is nobody, none of us,
knows what they're doing.
Nobody has a plan.
And if they have a plan,
they're just fooling themselves.
None of us know
what we're doing.
MOLLY STEVENS: And yet
we're all up here on stage.
JENNA BILOTTA: Any one of these
people could be up here too.
MOLLY STEVENS: So let's a
little bit about timing.
So about how you think
about starting something,
when you make decisions,
how you decide the launch
design changes, or
things like that.
The timing, I
think, is something
that is really relevant
to startup design.
And it comes up like, is it
too fast, is it too slow?
Do we know what our goals are?
Let anyone speak to
that a little bit?
BRADEN KOWITZ: I mean,
there's a tremendous amount
of randomness in the market.
Sometimes you can just start
your startup in a very bad time
macroeconomic time,
and sometimes you
can do the opposite.
And it's almost impossible for
everyone to tell where that is.
And so I think a
lot of it's getting
comfortable with that there's
a lot of luck in this industry,
and you have to
sail with the winds.
RYAN FREITAS: Well, that's
what it comes back to in terms
any person's story about
their startup success
is generally entirely
experiential.
You can't recreate a path,
there is no cookbook.
Timing is the devil
in the details.
You don't know what the
macroeconomic situation is
going to be in six months,
so do you raise now?
Do you raise later?
Do you focus on growth, do
you focus on engagement?
Do you focus entirely
on that partnership,
or bring in a strategic
partner as an investor that
could change the game for
you in terms of distribution.
Those decisions are
entirely weighted
by how aware you are of what's
going on in the larger picture.
I know plenty of founders
who are completely
heads down trying to make
their businesses work,
paying not any
piece of attention
to anything besides the quality
of the product and their bank
account.
And they'll figure
out when to raise
based on how low the amount
in the bank account is.
JENNA BILOTTA: And raising
is its own distraction.
Like you basically
stop all product--
if you're a designer that wants
to become a startup founder,
you have to get used to the
idea that the product is going
to move forward without you
for like three to six months
while you're fundraising.
Fundraising is a full-time job.
It's all-inclusive, and
it's so distracting.
It's distracting
for your employees,
and it's distracting for you.
I basically don't get
to do what I wanted
to do when I created a startup,
which is design a product
and ship it to the world.
You just have to go to
meetings with white dudes
in khaki pants, and it's
like, I like steak, too.
CHAD THORNTON: You have to
shipped an amazing product
of the world that
has many, many users.
So the output of what
you've done is that.
JENNA BILOTTA:
Well, it basically
gets frozen during fundraising.
So we have these periods
where we shift once a month
or every three weeks or
something, and by the way,
I do have an opinion on speed.
When you're a tiny startup
and with limited resources,
it's always too slow.
Everything you do is
always too slow based
on the number of
dollars that you have.
RYAN FREITAS: I don't think that
changes across the spectrum.
We're all under
ridiculous time pressure,
because there's
always an assumption
that something is going
to be on fire tomorrow.
And at the end, if it's not
public opinion, it's your base.
JENNA BILOTTA: Well, I think
in a place like Uber that's
in growth stage
right now, I think
that the leaders need to realize
when the inflection point is,
and deliberately slow
things down to be like, OK,
how are we going to
grow thoughtfully?
And how are we going to change
our product thinking more
deliberately?
But pre we're pretty
OK here, you just
got to go as fast as you can.
Just throw all the
spaghetti against the wall
and see what falls off.
CHAD THORNTON: I
think there's also
that-- so you guys have
talked about timing related
to raising money and all this.
You two both had
successful startups.
I had two startups
which are successful,
and I think that's a
tougher thing, too.
It's like, what's your
timing around saying
this isn't working?
I need to go make money, I
need to do something else
because just emotionally this
is like, it's going to kill me.
And that's a hard call to make.
RYAN FREITAS: So how
did you make the call?
CHAD THORNTON: That's
a good question.
I mean, the first one was easy,
we weren't getting funded.
RYAN FREITAS: Somebody else
made the decision for you.
CHAD THORNTON: The
second one was tougher.
The co-founder and I just
really weren't getting along.
And I think that was a
really hard learning lesson.
I should've done more
due diligence up front,
and figured out what
roles we were each going
to play, and just
accept that up.
And you just have
to realize, OK--
sunk cost is the worst cognitive
bias, because you're like,
I've sunk so much
time into this.
I just need to see
that something's
going to happen, right?
And then just to realize,
no, time for something else.
JENNA BILOTTA: The reality
check, the cold shower,
is something you
start asking yourself
when you get to 50% of your
initial seed investment
in your bank account.
You're like, is this working?
And then you just keep saying,
yeah, we're crushing it, yeah.
And then from that
day on, the first time
you ask yourself that
question, every single day you
ask yourself that question.
Is this working?
Is it time to
throw in the towel?
What are we doing?
And thinking about closing a
startup that you devoted all
your extra energy to is like
thinking about cutting off
your leg, well at
least for me anyway.
It's like having someone
suggest to me that I amputate
a part of my body that I worked
on that cell division really
hard to grow that leg.
And then you just
have to cut it off.
MOLLY STEVENS: So we've heard
about a lot of the positives
and negatives.
I want to hit on one more
positive before I have a couple
more serious questions.
What's the most
exciting moment for you
when you've launched a startup,
launched a design, co-founded.
There are a lot of
pain points, but what's
the most exciting moment?
BRADEN KOWITZ: For me going
from a big company to working
with startups,
the biggest change
was how hungry they
are for design work.
So if you're in a big company,
you've got your design
and you talk to the
engineers, and like, well,
I can't build half of that.
You talk to the product
managers and they all
want something different.
And your design gets eroded
into something very, very small.
And if you're an
agency, you ship
a lot of things over the
wall, and you're hoping,
I hope they build one of these.
And you're shipping, and
shipping, and shipping, right?
But at a startup, when I
started to work with them,
I was blown away with
how hungry they were.
So they would come
in with a problem,
and I would say, how
about something like this?
And they go, great.
And they build it the
next day and ship it.
That's so exciting,
and so different
than the way I was
used to working.
JENNA BILOTTA: I have a
really specific moment.
We screwed up our iOS mission
for our very first launch,
and it went out 24
hours in advance
of when we were actually
organizing all our press
releases and stuff.
And we got a phone call from
our lead iOS dev that says,
guys, we're live in the
store, and somebody just
bought the app.
And at the time, our app was
like five bucks or something
ridiculous so that we
could keep the crowd small.
We didn't know how we
were going to scale.
And that was the most
exciting moment for me.
I built something from
scratch that somebody
that I don't know, that
wasn't my friend or family,
paid money to use.
And that was the best
moment in Avocado history.
And it was a complete accident.
We were all out to dinner
celebrating the launch,
and we went live when no
one was paying attention.
But it was awesome.
RYAN FREITAS: When people
use what you built,
it's-- the whole rule in the
design business is don't design
for yourself.
The original version of
about.me was specifically
to solve a problem that we
thought five people had,
and then it just
turned into something
that millions of people
are using on a daily basis.
But it was a huge
cognitive shift for me
to be like, OK, these are
the things I would want,
this is the way I would
want to set it up.
This is different
from everything else,
and we're going to put it
out there into the world.
And for that to catch
on, or even for the brand
to be recognizable, or
when I introduce myself
and somebody says, oh yeah,
I have an about.me page.
That's just like something
going on in the back of my head,
because I didn't
expect any of this.
So it's a powerful thing.
It's dangerous, because
the ego latches onto that,
and you're like, OK
what does this mean?
JENNA BILOTTA: Don't worry,
it's a really short trip
from that high into the trough
of despair, so it's like a week
and then you're in the
trough of despair again.
So it's all good.
RYAN FREITAS: It's a good thing.
JENNA BILOTTA: It
might be that same day.
RYAN FREITAS: It
keeps you honest.
CHAD THORNTON: I would say
the same thing, it's growth.
I think more the point,
it's not intentional growth,
but it's growth because
you did something,
and then that thing
actually kind of panned out.
Not the accidental, threw
something at the wall and it
stuck.
JENNA BILOTTA: It's like, when
something happens intentionally
instead of by accident,
you're like, yay, I'm smart.
MOLLY STEVENS: So my
last question is serious.
And as I look at the room
and I think about the world,
and I recently moved
here from China.
So in the news, we hear
that startups and some
of the designers
are fairly elitist,
and don't really represent
the rest of the world, right?
Or the world we live in
or the problem we have.
So what will you
do as a designer,
or what do you do, to make
that not an issue next year?
JENNA BILOTTA: Chad.
CHAD THORNTON: The hard one.
I mean--
JENNA BILOTTA: Sorry.
CHAD THORNTON: So I
guess, just to clarify,
is this a question about
how to be more inclusive
on design teams, or--
MOLLY STEVENS: How
would you interpret it?
Because I think we could talk
about the inclusivity of teams,
but also the kinds of
products that we work on.
CHAD THORNTON: Yeah.
I mean honestly, I guess I'm
a big design education nerd,
so I think it actually
starts a lot earlier.
How do you get a wider
variety of people
to think about design
as a discipline that's
really exciting to them?
I was a biologist
as an undergrad,
and as a systems thinker, that's
shaped how I feel about things.
But I feel like we need more
of that breadth in the thinking
space of designers.
I guess to me that's like
inclusiveness, I guess.
JENNA BILOTTA: I think it's
hard to get away from this idea,
like I said, when you're
creating a new market,
you have to create a product
that you would want to use,
and you would understand.
And as a founder, you have
to be super, super passionate
about that idea, and be
a one minute active user
of your own product.
And so I think that
obviously we're here,
we have a certain
amount of privilege,
and those things don't
come naturally to say, oh,
how can I solve internet access
in third world countries that
don't have power?
But I do think that
designers are well
positioned through both
their empathy, and just
their holistic-- yeah, I know.
Hit the buzzer, I said empathy.
The people in this room are
going to solve those problems.
And we all need to be
better about pitching in
towards problems
that we can solve
that help the world
instead of problems
we're solving for ourselves.
But I think there's this
weird balance of what
are you going to give up your
whole life for when you create
a business and a product?
And I think it's really
hard to, at least initially,
be like, well, I'm going to do
that and just give it all away.
And I don't know,
it's a fine line.
RYAN FREITAS: Absolutely.
I come at it from
the perspective of I
can build a team that
represents a better mix.
You're talking
about inclusivity,
I'm just trying to find the best
possible talent that also makes
certain that they believe in
what we're trying to build.
But I also am keeping
an eye on-- we're
40% female on a 25-person team.
Which I'm proud of, but
it's not sufficient.
Like, it's one of those things
that's great, nice golf clap,
let's keep moving.
The bigger issue for me is,
is the product and the problem
that I'm working on
day-to-day basis really
all that important?
And that's, I
think, a little bit
of the commentary that's
been very frequent.
Does anybody need another
photo sharing app?
Does anybody need
another messaging app?
Well, yeah.
Does anybody need an
identity platform?
OK.
If I take a look at it
from that perspective,
no, but if I take a look
at it from the perspective
of democratizing
access, to being
able to represent
yourself online,
to taking some kind
of curatorial control
over how you are represented
in a Google search
results page or
something like that,
I feel like we're doing
something very important,
and I'm going to double
down on making certain
that most people that
can use it are using it
and are aware of
what we're building.
BRADEN KOWITZ: Yeah, I agree.
I think it can be
very easy to be
cynical about the
world of startups.
To pick out a couple startups
and say, oh, these people
are not making the world better.
But with startups, it's
a very big umbrella.
And I've been lucky
enough to work
with people that are helping
businesses get access to credit
where otherwise they
wouldn't to cancer care.
And just really important
stuff for the world.
And if you choose to
play in this arena,
you can choose where
you spend your time
and where you focus it.
JENNA BILOTTA:
The other thing is
that you don't really
know how people
are going to use
your products or how
it's going to change their lives
until you ship it to the world.
So we have a ton of military
couples using our app
to stay connected
remotely, and they're
able to hug their phone and hug
their enlisted spouse that's
halfway across the world.
And we had people using it to
keep track of Hurricane Sandy
damage where their
loved ones are.
And I think I've heard
stories of people
who were in labor, who couldn't
get a cab, they called an Uber.
You just never
know how-- there's
pockets of in our
selfishness to build products
that we want to use.
I think there's pockets of
truly affecting people's lives
in a positive way
that's not just
for 20-year-old
hooded Harvard grads.
RYAN FREITAS: Cynicism
is an easy gig.
I come back to this
a lot because we
were talking about this earlier.
Every co-founding team probably
needs a cynic and an optimist.
Someone to keep the wheels
on while the other person's
out there really selling
it, selling the vision.
Maybe even far beyond where
the reality of everything is.
Getting, as my co-founder
says, outkicking the coverage
every once in while.
But that cynicism
needs to not impact
the way we view the quality
and the type of work that
were doing.
There's always that
potential for something
beautiful to happen even in at
most base of problem solving.
MOLLY STEVENS: Excellent.
So I think we're going to take
questions from the audience
now.
So please, I don't
know if there's a mic
or if you just speak up.
There's a mic, so.
JENNA BILOTTA: Please
ask us questions.
We're all so lonely already.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
You mentioned the pain of having
to giving up the delight just
to focus more on
important tasks.
And you mentioned satisfying
investors where sometimes you
have to satisfy investors
that don't exist yet.
So my question is actually, what
do you think of-- or actually,
if and when should product
and design or user experience
should be separated to two
different people, or teams?
JENNA BILOTTA: I am the CPO
of my company of six people,
but yeah.
My co-founder and
I are responsible
for the long-term vision of
what we want the company to be,
and how we want it to grow.
But I'm responsible for
diving down into that.
And what does it look
like for the products?
What platforms are
we going to ship to?
I mean, we make a lot
of decisions together,
but then I think having
the same person responsible
for product and design
at a really small startup
is the right, I mean--
RYAN FREITAS: It's unavoidable.
JENNA BILOTTA: I'm
going to say it's
the correct thing,
because I'm an [BLEEP]
but I think it's the right thing
to do for really small company,
is to have the person
that's responsible
for the product
also be a designer.
RYAN FREITAS: But
there also needs
to be some kind of friction
between the way the business is
being run and the
design decisions
that are being made,
because otherwise it's
just the opportunity is
dictating the solution.
You need somebody actually
thinking critically
about how to get at the
solution, as opposed
to just saying, OK,
this is the market.
This is what we're going
to do from a dollar basis,
and these are the feature
set-- we asked everybody,
and this is the features
that we were told to build.
JENNA BILOTTA: If you're
looking for a co-founder
and you're a designer,
go for a business person.
Don't go for another designer
or another product person.
Two designer founders seems
like way too many cooks
in that kitchen already.
Seems like a disaster.
MOLLY STEVENS: All right.
Another question?
AUDIENCE: Hello, all.
JENNA BILOTTA: Hi, Sean.
AUDIENCE: So I have a question
that you guys talked about,
it's about motivation.
So designers as decision makers,
and people within companies,
it seems like they're looking
for more responsibility
for being closer to the
decisions that are made,
and so it seems like that might
be the motivation behind why
a designer might
decide to be a founder.
But then, from what
you guys are saying,
it sounds like a lot of the
responsibility that you pick up
doesn't really have anything
to do with design at all.
And then on top of
that, it can be lonely,
hard to stay human,
et cetera, et cetera.
So I guess maybe
personally for you guys,
as well as just in
general, what's the upside,
and does it really make
sense for a designer
to be a founder in order
to get more responsibility?
Or is it really something
else that drives you?
RYAN FREITAS: I have
one thing on this.
Because I've been
listening to designers
complain about not having
a seat at the table
for going on 20 years.
It's ludicrous.
You have a seat at the table,
just sit the [BLEEP] down.
There's this perceived
or learned helplessness
on the part of the
design community
that they can't get involved
in business decisions,
or that no one wants them there,
or they don't have a voice,
you're welcome.
There's an opportunity
to get in there.
You are no longer laughed
at in pitch meetings
because you're a
designer and you're
sitting down with a
business co-founder
in order to get something built.
That's one thing.
The second piece
is, yes, absolutely,
if you are a
designer and you feel
like you want to have some
control over the thing that's
going to be built, or
the thing that you're
going to work on for either
the rest of your life
or for the next 10 years,
absolutely, take the jump.
There's no reason not to.
JENNA BILOTTA: I'm
going to say no to that.
Because if the only reason
that you're starting a startup
is to be the boss of
something, then don't do it.
Because you will burn
out on your idea,
you'll burn out on your product,
you'll pivot a million times,
and then you'll sink into
the trough of despair anyway.
You have to have both the
willingness and the desire
to be the person that
the buck stops with,
which is an outrageously huge
and devastating responsibility
because designers take
things into themselves.
But the [BLEEP] umbrella is
really hard for a designer,
because you just
absorb the empathy,
you absorb it all into
yourself, but you have nowhere
to output it to.
I would say that unless
you have an idea that's
burning a hole in your
brain, and the drive
to want to be your
own boss and be
responsible for
other people's lives.
If you have one or
the other, at least
from my personal
experience, I would not
do it if you are
not just waking up
at night thinking of the
same idea for like a year.
BRADEN KOWITZ: On
the other hand,
designers have such
an amazing skill
set for founding companies.
We are so good at
faking things, and we
can make stuff just
look good on the veneer
but actually be
nothing underneath,
like it's just a little
prototype or whatever.
That's totally what you
need to start a startup.
And it depends on what
you consider design.
If all you consider design is
the visual layer, then yeah,
you're not going to be
getting to do much of that.
But if you consider design as
figuring out what people really
need and crafting an
organization of culture that
can deliver that to
them, your design work
is designing the team,
and then absolutely you
can still be a designer.
JENNA BILOTTA: I
would also say there's
a huge difference in the
drive to make a product,
and the drive to create
a company or a business.
Those two are
completely separate,
and well, they're
mostly separate.
But you got to
figure out deep down
in your soul searching, whether
you want to make a product
or whether you want
to make a business.
CHAD THORNTON: It
sounds weird to say,
but some of most thrilling
moments in the last year
I was working on were more about
designing the business model
than about designing the
nuances of the product.
So if you can find a way
to get excited about that,
then that opens up so
many possibilities.
MOLLY STEVENS: More questions?
One over there.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thanks guys.
My question is about the problem
of protecting a successful part
of your business or product,
versus really quickly doing
the necessary iteration
and innovation
to take it to the next level.
I think it affects
every product.
Maybe for each company
it's different.
I think Uber definitely needs
to protect the fundamental part
of its business that is
incredibly successful,
but maybe it's a
problem or question
about a local [INAUDIBLE].
But how do you approach
that and continue
to innovate while also
being successful, I guess?
RYAN FREITAS: That's
an Uber question.
BRADEN KOWITZ: It's definitely
a big business question.
I think when you're small,
you don't have much to risk,
so you can just do all
sorts of crazy stuff.
RYAN FREITAS: Yeah, but
you also have to-- I
think where you innovate
is at the fringes.
And you try to innovate
at the outside and go in.
Like one of the things
we're learning right now,
building tools that
help our users turn
their pages into a deliverable
of some kind to other people.
So we just released
a app called Intro
with the sole purpose,
the only thing it does
is make introductions and
turns your about.me page
into a digital business card.
We are hoping that that
pattern-- and we're competing
with literally handing a
physical business card over
to somebody else.
We're hoping that pattern
informs other ideas around how
our users receive
the page, and how
they want to engage with it.
I'm not trying to mess with any
of the representation tools,
any of the feed, any of
that yet until I understand
what the behaviors
that I'm engendering
with these small
pieces, what they have
to do with the rest
of the product.
CHAD THORNTON: I think
within product teams,
it's easy to say
this product's going
to do a lot of hill climbing.
And this product line
or set of features
is really going to take
the big step forward.
I think it's a lot harder
for one team to say,
OK, now is the
time to hill climb,
and now we're going
to take some time
and actually do something
really different.
Those are different
dispositions,
and that's a really hard
thing to get within one team.
RYAN FREITAS: The
biggest problem also
is within a large organization,
you wind up with the Microsoft
problem where Office
becomes the core,
and you don't mess
with Office, and you
let Office innervate everything,
and no one can-- it's
sacrosanct.
Sacrosanct is the worst thing
that can possibly happen,
because it means that
you're not paying attention
to-- it may be the
core of the business,
but it immediately
becomes revenue-driven,
and it's making
decisions for everyone
else in the organization.
It just seems really dangerous.
JENNA BILOTTA: It's
especially weird
when you think about the
core of a successful business
probably was an accident anyway.
And that it wasn't really
intentionally successful.
It's really weird to
think about protecting it.
But as soon as it
starts making money,
you just feel like
you can't turn off
the money faucet for any reason.
But then companies get
into this situation,
where if they don't become the
next version of themselves,
somebody else will.
Because there's a lot of us out
there that are really hungry,
and we're sacrificing our
lives to build something great,
and you never know.
We're also going to trip
into our own successes, too.
MOLLY STEVENS: One more
question, if there is one.
There's one here in the front.
AUDIENCE: Hey, guys.
My name's Matt, and I
have a little bit more
of a product-centered question.
When you guys come up with
ideas for what to build
and you show it to your
friends, virtually everyone's
going to give you
positive feedback.
But I'm curious how you
guys qualify whether or not
something is worth solving,
or worth your time?
JENNA BILOTTA: Well first
of all, not everybody
gives you-- I mean, maybe you
have better friends than I do.
But the first
versions of Avocado
we showed to people, people were
like, oh, why would I use that?
I have SMS.
What are you doing?
You're wasting your
life, kind of situation.
But I think that that's where
the business mind comes in.
So if you're a designer
looking for a co-founder,
having somebody that's
really business-savvy,
or taking that on
yourself to identify what
are the characteristics
of the market?
When you're in early
stage, seed-stage startup,
the thing that you'll hear
from everybody on Earth
is product market fit,
product market fit,
do you have product market fit?
I challenge one
person in this room
to really clearly define
that in one sentence.
What does that mean?
Nobody knows.
You're trying to solve a problem
for some set of users that
don't have a clear
set of attributes,
and you're basically
out there trying
to define what that
set of attribute is.
And then you have
to think, well,
how big is that
set of attributes?
How big are the people
that fit into that bucket?
And can I build a
business off of this,
or is this like a side
project where I just
want to make a
really cool product
for a small number of people?
And that's a decision
you have to make,
whether to actually throw some
money behind legal fees and all
that, or whether you're just
going to make it and ship it
into the world and
see what happens.
RYAN FREITAS: I think at
the beginning, at least,
being self-critical
is highly important.
Being able to take a step back.
In writing, in
design, in everything.
It's helpful to
both have someone
to be an editor
to help you with,
but you also have to
take a perspective of,
this thing that I've
created is not perfect.
The internal voice needs
to be negative towards it.
Over time, you'll learn
putting stuff on the world,
you need a very thick skin
because people will absolutely
tear you apart.
I mean, I build a free product.
The amount of critique
that I receive,
I have to not let it get to me.
I have to be aware of what I'm
trying to do and the problem
that I'm trying to solve.
Because if I let what--
the editor of Valleywag
told me that my
product was shit.
OK, great, that's just
your opinion, man.
I just have to be
able to move on.
But if you're in the
early days, if you're
getting a bunch of
positive feedback,
that might get you to the point
where you can put something out
in the world and
get the real stuff.
And I heartily encourage
you to put it out there
into the world, because it's a--
JENNA BILOTTA: I have
one last question.
Would you do it again?
RYAN FREITAS: Not
the way I did it.
JENNA BILOTTA: What about you?
CHAD THORNTON: Not right now.
JENNA BILOTTA: Would you do it?
BRADEN KOWITZ: Would
I start a company?
Absolutely.
MOLLY STEVENS: And would you?
JENNA BILOTTA: I'm a no.
I'm a firm no.
MOLLY STEVENS: All right.
On that note, very
interesting discussions.
Thank you all so
much for the panel,
and thank you for listening.